okay so I'm doing these two back-to-back
because it's sort of two parter it's the
invasion and the Eclipse and I will omit
one of the downsides of having this on
DVD is that you sort know this is the
big attack the big moment and there's
still two more discs left mmm I got to
take a wild guess and say things aren't
going to go according to plan
so that that kind of sucks but on the
other hand where's it gonna go and I
really enjoy going into this knowing
well this is like the big climax of any
other show or story but we're only about
halfway through this season so what's
going to happen I don't think they're
gonna do like a million endings I can
lure the Rings so what's gonna happen so
it's it's nice knowing there's going to
be more about the same time it is
they're like a dad you know it's not
going to go going to plan or the Fire
Nation is aware or something so that's
pretty much what this is this is the
beginning of the invasion the big attack
and the Fire Nation all these old
characters come back together which is
wonderful I love seeing a lot of these
characters again some of my had to be
reminded of and they do a good job
reminding you for example that one kid
that Katara broke out of prison and his
father like I totally forgot who he was
and they reminded me and I'm like oh
good and I did in a good way that wasn't
pure exposition in fact it was very
clever Toph is there and she goes who's
this who's that and again they put it
all together very nicely so he would
make sense they would have to explain
what this is uh I was gray seeing the
Avenger again was great seeing the
wrestlers again I love the fact that the
boulder was in there I don't know why I
love the boulder it's just love I don't
know he makes me laugh um so you got
this battle going on you get Aang and
finally kisses Katara well I mean that
they already sort of did in the cave but
I mean like confesses hey you know I'm
unbelievably hugely in love with you and
you mean the world and all that stuff
I didn't I kind of go without saying in
the cave though I I don't know about
stretching that out but it's still a
very nice genuine heartfelt moment I
like that they did it in in action as
opposed to words and again
it felt like it all came through that
one action just the kiss was very very
effective uh so I thought that was good
and then he takes off like a
motherfucking badass I love that it's a
perfect
it's an epically romantic moment I
thought worked out very very well um and
they have these machines I always
something about the machines like the
ships and the tanks look a touch strange
to me in this world um but it's it's
their world they can sort of do whatever
they want but I know they're going for
it sort of like you know sort of this
Asian history a type of world and to see
sort of like these tanks and they're
there whatever those centipede things
that went up the stairs they're cool as
hell uh they took me out a touch but
nothing too bad they're still cool and
again you sort of realize you can get
away with the stuff in this kind of show
seeing the hot air balloons return that
was great but then seeing that giant ass
holy shit-fuck ship come out behind it
was even better because you know the
balloons are coming back you know they
built it up and okay well when are they
won are they gonna make the big return
and they do but see that other giant
ship come behind it so not only did they
master this technology but they pushed
it even further I was so great and it
makes sense because it's it's the Fire
Nation they have they have more people
they have more time they have the Empire
so it makes sense uh so the battle
itself was fun I liked Sokka sort of
taking the reins and leading the battle
and fathers out of commission uh there's
one moment I district oh this this seems
a little weird which is I think it's
after Aang
the Fire Lord is now where he should be
and he comes back in the middle of the
battle and all these it's like in the
middle of this battle and debris is
flying and stuff and seeing sort of like
the soldiers were just standing around
while all this stuff is being thrown up
and granted they sort of have these uh
the whatchamacallit the machines are
blocking them but wouldn't they be
ducking a little bit more wouldn't be a
little bit more debris when they are
when the fire
no sir come around the other end and Jed
I don't know I get that's real
nitpicking um it could have been a bit
more intent that they were having this
argument while sort of screaming at each
other and and debris and stuff is fine
but real nitpicking um I like that uncle
Iroh cuz that was another big common
thing it's Iroh but hey hey a lot of
people were saying Sookie and I heard
Sokka clearly say Sookie in this one
Sookie is I okay again i I really don't
get I'm reading more into I'm being
drawn into that name argument it's like
there's more important things people so
I'm gonna call Sookie from now on
because that's what Sokka called her and
I'm if I show calls her that ass why I'm
calling her Oh but regardless I love a
Azula bringing up Suki because at first
I thought she was talking about like
sokka's mother or something like way Mae
what was she imprisoned or something
then we find out Suki it's like oh okay
so um yeah I'll be happy to see again
they're leaving that a mystery where is
she is she still a prisoner there did
she did they kill her off it's unlikely
they killed her off but holy shit
wouldn't that be it's always would that
be dark um so you got that so going on
it's a great battle with us it's great
seeing these people even though their
powers are taken away that they can
still really really fight that is to say
the like Azula and which we call it Zuko
and so forth
they can still fight regardless I like
seeing that because it's just smart and
I'm sort of wondering how did they know
about the invasion to the explain that
before I don't think so I think they're
building that up for a reveal later but
but that's a good mystery how did they
know did they just have spies or
whatever um I I like the earth Kingdom
people coming in helping us ooh limey
it's like I like this was a
well-thought-out plan I like her just
having them chase her like I get that
was really smart and how she can work
into their emotions and get them pissed
off at all that's just it's a great plan
um I love that
Zuko is finally coming around and I like
that he it seems like he has a chance to
kill his father but he does and he says
that's the avatars job that's his
destiny
you could argue to behead him right
there
giant war come on but I don't know it
seems like even though they kill the
Fire Lord just whatever next in line of
Zula or the prince or whatever I mean
then they're gonna be just I mean Zuko
would be okay you know obviously but I
mean he'll whatever they do I either be
assassinated or they take him out or
something Emmy Azula would be the next
in power so it's like it seems like
either way there's still be kind of
screwed um unless again I'm missing
something about the bloodline or
something but Zoo goes now off and he's
gonna go if I with the avatars last
thing you see is him following following
Aang
gonna obviously try to help him on his
journey yeah which is great to see it's
great to see the whole Redemption which
you know it's coming but it's nice to
see it it's nice to see him really come
to that conclusion be like okay let's
let's go all the way with this oh I do
hope him in the uncle you know it didn't
beat up again I'm sure they will uh but
yeah that's definitely one of the points
why how did you get out of that jail
cell by the way I mean that's that's
fuckin metal and he's not to even Toph
had to spend like hours maybe even like
days inside that canister thing I mean
just by herself just trying to you know
hone in on the power or the ability and
the element of metal to bed how did he
get out I don't care how strong he is
that's I don't know maybe though show it
uh I've had I kind of questioned a bit
uh but if regardless it was great to see
him get out and uh oh yeah what else
what else the the big element for me
that I really liked that in most other
cases and this could be in most other
cases I say this is kind of like
repetitive writing and that's that Aang
has failed before he's going in again to
redeem himself and in a sense he has
failed again or he's been outsmarted at
the very least because the Fire Lord is
not there and he couldn't find him and
he couldn't fight uh to feed him uh so
I like the fact that they're building up
this is going to be his big Redemption
any other show or movie that would be
the climax and he will redeem himself yo
now it's payback and he gets his payback
and he could die in the process but he
still gets his payback and it's like no
he it doesn't even happen it's another
failure and I think that is important I
think that's important thing to set up
because I think a lot of people do sort
of think well next time it'll be
different and it always will be
different and the second time is where
you build up all the energy and all the
power and all the strategy and you're
gonna win this time and it doesn't
always happen and again that doesn't
always mean give up uh if there are some
times where the writing is on the wall
and you have to accept it and that is
sort of what happened here they could
keep looking for the fire Lord but they
knew people out there could be dying and
they probably are dying they had to go
back and they had to help him they have
to escape they have to fight another day
and this was supposed to be the big
Redemption and it's not and that's just
such another tough defeat to take and on
top of that and now the children are
being separated from the parents and
Aang has to go up there and he has the
responsibility looking after these
people and he probably has to hear over
and over at least in his head that he
has failed them and now the adults are
all in prison or being tortured or
whatever and it's just so much more to
be thrown on him and like I said in any
other show I would say this is too
repetitive because we've seen this we've
seen him be harsh on himself and say I'm
not going to fail again and he fails
again but you know that happens it does
happen and I'm curious to see where
they're gonna go with that because they
seem to be very good at taking these
emotions you think are going to go in a
certain direction or emotions are going
to lead to a certain outcome and that
outcome doesn't happen and they seem to
work with that very well they seem to
know what to do with that and not become
too repetitive so I'm very curious how
how they're going to have egg deal with
this because this is in some respects so
much
worse than before because he had the
time now and he had the ability and
everything was said that he was still
outsmarted and just the amount of pain
that's going to cause and it just it
made things so much worse because now
all these people are in prison and like
said now he's looking after all the
younger people in this group and it's
just so painful and I'm curious to see
how he's going to get through that and
the big element of the show seems to be
that persistence that when you fail it's
all right it or if I even all right it's
just gonna happen you're going to fail
and you have to keep finding a way of
living with that whether it's
confronting it again or trying to change
it or whether you just had to live with
it and I like that they're doing this
because they're really switching it
around with Zuko and Aang and before it
was really Zuko that was constantly
failing and he had to really question
what he was doing it for and and how he
was going to do it and why and now you
have ain't doing the same thing and what
are the best moments to do this what's
the worst moment what's more important
in these moments where do you go how do
you do it
it's great seeing this sort of switch
and it's not but it's not super obvious
all the time
like I said I mean right now Sukho if
they want to do it Zuko would still be
with the father and he wouldn't confront
him but instead he's gonna go with the
avatar so he has an evolution as well in
his character while Aang seems to be
falling more and more uh so in terms of
achievements anyway you know is he he
couldn't defeat the Fire Lord if
anything he's made things worse so I
like seeing this all sort of balancing
out the sort of balancing act and it's
not always I was really afraid for a
while that just the whole show all the
seasons was gonna be Zuko chasing him
and I'm glad it's not I'm glad early in
the second season
Zuko decides to leave the Fire Nation
and other people are after him and I'm
glad that in the third season it's very
much like they were defeated and now
it's time to rise back up and it's the
fight back
how do you do it will it even be
successful because now they're
introducing these possibilities at least
in the realm of this world that it may
be it won't be successful this was like
their big moment and it totally got
fucked up so I'm I'm even though we know
it's gonna turn out good in the end
again take a look at um you know you
know it's gonna be alright but you don't
know how and you don't know the journey
that they're gonna go through and they
make this journey so fascinating and so
enjoyable and so heavy and so deep and
so well thought out that I'm so looking
forward to where this is gonna go and it
doesn't just feel like repetitive
writing so I very much enjoy that they
had this surf in the middle of the third
season and not the end I think that was
very very clever because now you don't
know exactly where it's gonna go
or rather how it's gonna get there I
should say so and you know they do say
what happened to the mother I had so
many people sending me messages like
yeah you never find out what happens to
the mother that's never explained she's
vanished I mean that's that's all I need
I don't need to really know what happens
to her afterwards if I do great if not I
totally accept the fact that's just
something she has to live with I was
referring more to why was she leaving
and they do they say that she's banished
so that only makes sense I'm cool with
that if that's where they stop that's
fine and I dunno there's a comic so what
actually gave me the comic at the con
was the the promise and I did look the
remote because I'm like I gotta wait til
I get through the season um but yeah I
mean it's I'm totally cool with that and
it I have to read what happens to her
that's fine too but they didn't go in
any more detail that's fine you know
that's that's life sometimes you never
find out where these people go uh I
would say the only are nitpick before I
wrap up here uh you know they finally
show this fire Lord and they've been
building up his appearance I'd be
keeping me in shadow and they finally
see him he's not scarred and disfigured
and so he's this very almost peaceful
looking person I think that's much more
frightening and I was kind of looking
forward to a little bit more sort of
like maybe the Emperor from Star Wars
that's a-that's comparison I can come up
with right now
where
everything is sort of in his court even
if things go wrong it's sort of like he
wouldn't show if he would be very
heartless and almost I have no emotion
when Zuko confronts and though he seems
legit like what why would you lie about
that oh you little scar you little
pocket you know so you're going to do
this no LM a I would have liked it if
there was a little less emotion I think
that's when he looks the most
frightening and the most scary um
anything else just sort of makes him
look like I don't want to say a thug but
certainly your traditional villain and
this is like the top guy this is your
Hitler this is your everyone wants to
figure out what the hell's going on
inside his mind type character and they
then that think I'm almost a little too
simple um and sometimes a villain is
very simple even the ones we think are
the most complicated but I don't know if
that I cut seen something a little bit
more there but they also do address
sorry the idea behind the fire nation
and why the takeover was happening sort
of I don't see why there's still good
people in the Fire Nation but what the
ideology is I think they did in the
backstory with the avatar in the Fire
Lord
and here was Zuko really realizing how
much the world hates the Fire Nation and
how it's actually justified that he was
actually sort of under this delusion
that they were spreading something good
and maybe that was kind of the original
intention of the Fire Nation
but now it's gotten from spreading
something good and making it all equal
the ultimate equalizer whether the world
realizes it's good for it or not to just
keeping the power it's no longer what is
best what they feel is best for the
world it's just about keeping that power
and I think that was pretty effective
and I think it's so easy just to show
evil empire and that's it and the show I
mean in the opening they have to
simplify I mean this very complex
backstory in its opening very quickly I
think they do a pretty good job but
there is sort of this fear oh is this
just gonna be their bad and that's it uh
would they I think is something it may
be something that's a little bit more I
don't want say more adult but in in
something that wasn't just meant for
families it actually them say that
what's where I'm looking for I mean
something that is hey this is only for
adults
and screw the kids you know as good the
families this is only for adults they
could have gone to more detail about it
but I think for a family show to get
everybody involved to still have
everybody understand and keep everybody
on the page and keep coming back to it
they balanced it out pretty well
explaining what they were originally
trying to do and how it has sort of
changed how it has become just wanting
to keep this status quo and keep all
this power and control as opposed to
wanting to do something better for the
worlds i I think that was a good balance
so uh yeah that's a lot of talking but
again it is two episodes and I greatly
enjoyed it uh mentally looking forward
to where it goes next so yeah uh I'll
see you wherever it goes next